David were back talking about acts and
up till now we've heard a little bit
about about the formation of the early
church and about some of the
persecutions that were taking place
especially of Stephen and we've thought
a little bit about some of the major
themes that Luke is articulating
continuity and discontinuity we talked a
little bit about the temple last time
and we had the introduction of the
figure of Paul Ross Saul at this point
who was there at the execution of
Stephen so the next stage of the game
sees a little bit more of Paul playing a
role although Peter and Paul are also
both on stage during these next several
chapters chapter 9 is pretty critical
for introducing Paul it's his conversion
experience right right what do you make
of this is this history is it fiction
what's going on with this story my sense
is that that it has deep historical
roots whether the protect your
particular details are historically
accurate is tricky I think through all
of the book of Acts but it comes very it
becomes a kind of dramatic description
of what Paul describes more thematically
in the first two chapters of Galatians
where it's clear that there was some
remarkable experience that shifted his
way of being in his way of understanding
himself not precisely necessarily the
way that Luke described it but I think
this is this is extremely important in
luton Paul's own self understanding and
extremely important for Luke because it
comes in three times once there's a
third-person description and twice Paul
recounts that of himself as a way of
talking about the old Paul in the new
Paula Paul it was a persecutor and the
Paul who is now among the persecuted
among the among the various sect he was
trying to destroy so I think it said I
think an extraordinarily important
moment in the book of Acts and probably
an extraordinary important moment in
Paul to himself consciousness so in
Paul's own self description of the
revelation he received Christ in
Galatians there's no sort of Damascus
Road experience we don't have the voices
we don't have the lights we just have
the the strong claim that the Lord
appeared also to him and strikingly in
Paul's description in Galatians a major
reason he wants to stress this and again
in 1st Corinthians 9
is to make clear that he's as much an
apostle as the others and that he's an
apostle because he saw the risen Lord
interestingly when Newt tells the story
there's no hello be my apostle because
for Luke the apostles of that circle of
12 I think for the most part and Paul
doesn't qualify on the same head Paul
needs a little bit of instruction in
Luke all these considerable instruction
in Luke and he gets that in the presence
of Ananias and I in Paul and I want not
to make this a seminar on Paul which my
students dad do anyway on everything but
Paul is extraordinarily self-confident
but even he will admit from time to time
in his epistles that he received this
from someone else and I think we get in
the sense of Ananias the fact that Paul
is tradition into a movement that's
really there before him and the idea
that sometimes abroad that Paul's really
the founder of Christianity the thing
actually doesn't work he's that's most
articulate at least his most published
advocate in that first generation but he
comes into a community that's there and
with people who know how to instruct him
and Ananias is one of those in Paul's
own telling he goes up to Jerusalem and
learns of things from the Apostles there
so there was some there's some sense
that this is not just not just me right
mm-hmm right so Paul begins to play a
role here but Peter still dominates the
action in these a couple of chapters
right he does very much soul and what
kinds of actions do we see Peter engaged
well we say Peter I think engaged in in
a broadening of his own sense of mission
a broadening of his own sense of what
God is doing through this Christian
mission and and we've seen it in a way
when he when he preaches at Pentecost to
the multilingual people now he's has to
face the really difficult question
whether this is a gospel that we have
will be a gospel available to the
Gentiles as well and I think for him
that's a major breakthrough in terms of
in terms of what his self understanding
has been and we see that especially in
his relationship to Cornelius and in the
vision that they both have of a
community that is no longer just for
Jews whether proselytes or born Jews but
is actually now opening up to Gentiles
who have not been part of that community
say a little bit about that vision
because there's a little bit of a
disconnect isn't there between the
content of the vision
vision the vision is a vision of all
kinds of animals and beasts and kinds of
food being lowered down from heaven on a
sheet and Paul says I can't eat that
because it's presumably not kosher
Peter Peter said I can't eat that
because presumably it's not kosher and
God says that you call nothing I've made
unclean and then Peter decides that he
needs to do it and the issue is not the
issue in the drama is not what can you
eat it's with whom can you associate and
to whom can you invite to be part of
that whom can you invite to be part of
this community but if so it becomes a
kind of metaphor though it's interesting
we'll see when we get to chapter 15 that
the metaphor comes back around again and
the question of what Gentiles are going
to have to eat also becomes important in
the church but at this point I think
it's a kind of symbol of vision for the
larger sense of community which doesn't
make that distinction between cleaner
hungry we had a little bit with the
eunuch right we were already were
already breaking down those clean
uncle'd lines and ways of course the
eunuch was probably a proselyte oh yeah
almost certainly but but the idea of the
kingdom going beyond the kind of most
narrow limits of sexual normality and
all that
I think begins to break through and here
Cornelius is definitely a Gentile
courtiers is definitely agenda Cornelius
may be the kind of person that
Theophilus may be he may be one of those
Gentiles who is hung around the
synagogue enough that he actually knows
something of the story the sacred
history that Luke refers to God a
so-called God fear the god-fearers of
those who who were in our parlance
friends of the church haven't quite made
the final move of pledging or being
circumcised or being kosher or whatever
you need to be but nonetheless are
sympathetic and open to the kind of
messages that they're hearing the
synagogue
so if Peter is the person who affects
the conversion of the first Gentile and
acts what does that say about Luke's
understanding of the relationship
between Peter and yeah well my sense is
that that in in the book of Acts Peter
and Paul are much more on the same page
than they are in Paul's own recounting
of their relationship where it seems to
be more troubled and more problematic
and where I think Paul on the whole
associates Peter with the more real
in a group about about reaching out of
the Gentile mission and I think this is
partly it's it's the kind of the analogy
I use with my students is that when I
was in sixth and seventh grade my
assumption was that Hamilton and
Jefferson and Washington and Franklin
got together on a regular basis for
cigars and brandy and agree on the
future of the country and that when I
became a man or an adult I discovered
that many things they disagreed about
all kinds of things but the kind of the
kind of party line not a stupid party
line is that that this group this nation
was founded by people in great agreement
I think Luke wants to say that this
church this movement of which were a
part was founded by these great leaders
who were very much in agreement about
these issues when we read Galatians
especially it's not quite so clear that
Paul and Peter were were that much of
the same Mont and sometimes in Galatians
Paul will refer to Peter semi's are
casting lis is a kind of a so-called
pillar of the church and I I suspect
Peter didn't think he was a so-called
pillar of the church it doesn't Paul
also say that there was an agreement
that Peter would let Peter get to the
Gentiles first in an important way and
then Paul follows that example and
follows it hugely but he follows it and
this picks up a little bit on that thing
that we talked about timbre two ago
about the Apostles being sort of a the
core of the leadership of the church
even though they don't do enough a lot
solidity of authority there yeah there's
a way in which I think well I think you
can trace through although I haven't
done this with any great care you can
trace who the Apostles and and so the
Apostles almost have to validate that
Gentile mission for it to be valid then
Paul and then from Paul to the elders
and then from the elders to us or to the
generation that reads these stories so
that from my Baptist perspective
perspective as opposed to some people
with a different version of apostolic
succession
we've always argued the apostolic
succession is a succession of the
teaching from generation to generation
rather than the succession of ordination
but there's strongly sense of continuity
in in Luke and accent nobody makes this
up including Paul now one interesting
feature here about the importance of
this Cornelius episode is that the
repetition yeah we have the story told
and then we had our Peter retell right
so Luke in Festus I think I think
looking back we look at Pentecost as
being so crucial and we look at acts 15
as being circle but I suspect just in
terms of the emphasis and the dramatic
power that this story of Peter and
Cornelius is almost the hinge of Acts
story because the gospel really does now
move from the people of Israel to that
larger world there are a couple of other
interesting things that go on and in
these chapters and so we have the
Gentiles coming in we have this very
interesting vision that also has some
implications for kashrut
but then we have a deliverance story
Peter being delivered from prison and
they're not the first time that this is
not right this is in chapter 12 it's not
what what do you make of that episode
and the sequel to it
yeah well a couple of things first of
all I think that the the prison stories
become kind of paradigmatic of what Luke
wants to say acts wants to say is the
situation of the church which is that we
are constantly endangering constantly
redeemed will see it happen to Paul in
its own way in an interesting way it
happened to Jesus between the
crucifixion the resurrection and I think
the life of the church is constant
danger nonetheless God's still in charge
there's also humor in this one because
when Peter gets out you remember he
comes up to the to the door and knocks
on the door and Rhoda who's one of the
disciples this is the house of beer man
Rhoda is so excited that she rather than
saying come in Peter right she's - and
says Peters out there Peter's alive and
they say well Peters repeaters rescued
from jail and they say well where is
Peter all I forgot to bring him in right
I think Luke's a great storyteller he's
got Saul standing there when Stephen
gets martyred he brings a little bit of
sense of the fact that God has a good
sense of humor at this point this is
almost a comic interlude it's a calming
interlude in the midst of a story that's
in some ways getting increasingly heavy
because we have a couple of deaths
framing this right
James and then the death of Herod and
the death of Herod right which is kind
of grisly is extraordinary grisly and I
suspect he had it coming he's in there
somewhere in some kind of sense that
this is the gut for 4x I think Luke and
acts more than any other book in the old
in the New Testament it's not just that
God is in charge of our human lives our
individual lives and not even just that
God's in charge of the church the wall
that is true but God is the great
playwright of this larger story that
includes Herod as it included Caesar
Augustus back at the beginning which
Herod is this by the way there are a
number of Herod's the plural yes this is
grandson of the great right so Herod
Agrippa the first thank you very much I
knew all those things once I used to
know the family tree okay so then we
have Peter and Paul playing a major role
earlier and but in sync right right and
we also learned one other interesting
feature here about the the church as a
whole its name is Christian right for
the first time according to Luke yeah
that took place in Antioch and yeah what
do you make of that is that a historical
detail I don't see why not how's that I
can't think of any particular reason why
he would put that within there if there
wasn't some kind of reminiscence that
this this movement this way for
self-identified as Christian Antioch and
Antioch seems to have been and we all
through acts seems to be there at key
moments I suspect that was the home of a
fairly flourishing Christian community
yeah I think that's probably right and
it's a Greek term right so right it's a
designation for rice this group right
right the piano's is a Greek term yeah
right probably a derogatory term yeah
those Christ's people that exactly right
would have first arisen in a place like
Antioch where they could have been
thought of at the same time is that
makes a certain amount of sense it does
was like the Quakers mmm-hmm who thought
of thought of themselves as friends and
everybody else thought of as Quakers
because they quaked
and they've kind of owned that now
they're not they're not ashamed to be
Quakers Christians weren't ashamed to be
Christians so the church is is
flourishing despite all this persecutor
supply at all this presentation
sometimes through all this persecution I
think right we'll see more of this
coming up it keeps coming